hey youtubers it's Charlie so netflix
confirmed on their back end that
punisher season one is coming 2017
there's going to be a breakdown
they've already announced their
showrunner they're already looking at a
couple of characters so just explain
everything
if you didn't see it I didn't defenders
trailer breakdown i talked a little bit
about how Jon Bernthal popped his head
in a comic con at the netflix panel was
just like hey everybody just want to say
thanks
he had this super beard on it was
freaking huge but he's just so thankful
to the fans for the awesome response
that they gave him for his portrayal and
just reminding everyone 2017 Punishers
coming here and say it officially but
they did say that we're working on
weaving punisher into the larger
defenders universe because a lot of the
punisher stuff didn't blow up till after
they've already made all these
contractual arrangements to produce the
defender series and all the different
shows so before they ever rolled cameras
on daredevil season one they had
contracts in place for when each season
would drop how many episodes they be and
when they would team up and defenders so
it's almost like they planned the whole
phase of movies like they've been all
the way through the avengers from the
first iron man movie ahead of time then
when punisher came along and blew up
everyone went crazy they're like oh my
god we have to find a way to do more of
this
well of course the answers to do
spin-off series but they were so tight
up with the plans to make all these
other series that they had to adjust a
little bit so they're still kind of
figuring that out
so even if it gets pushed a little bit i
still think that will see punisher
season one before the end of 2017
you just might get pushed to the ass end
of 2017 so like november december
so all the new characters that Marvel
can do TV series for on netflix
Punishers probably the perfect fit and
because of the context with which they
used him in daredevil season two like
the way they introduce them into this
universe there are actually a number of
really easy jumping off points for where
he can go with his first season
select the overarching villain the one
who ties everything together is Wilson
Fisk is kind of like the thanos of
the Netflix series even though he's only
going to be one of the villains of the
defenders team up but during daredevil
season 2 he and Punisher had it out and
he let him know in no uncertain terms
that the minute he got out of prison he
would be gunning for punisher just like
he'd be gunning for daredevil and for
Nelson and Murdock because even though
you might wonder kingpin does not know
that Matt Murdock is daredevil yet he'll
probably figured out eventually but it
doesn't really matter because he wants
to kill both of them so either way back
Murdock is in deep shit just like the
punisher is in deep shit but the easiest
sell in terms of punisher villains are
the mob that was mostly what he did
during daredevil season two is he went
after mob targets that he felt were
culpable in the death of his family so
naturally he killed a couple of
high-level people like the Irishman when
the Irishman threatened to kill his dog
oh man you just can't come back from
that the minute you threaten someone's
dog you have to die
that's the TV shows way of telling you
that there's people out there that are
way worse than the punisher as crazy as
the punisher is you do not hurt animals
so I feel like a really easy thing for
them to do with punisher is him going
after human traffickers because if you
remember during daredevil season one
they tried to bring in that black sky
child so there's a lot of human
trafficking that goes down at the docks
Punishers just like the first person you
would expect to be on that now like
daredevil and Punisher do overlap a
little bit because the hand aside the
biggest villains in Hell's Kitchen in
that area of the city are drug dealers
in the mob the kingpin naturally is
going to be getting out of prison soon
we'll start consolidating mob forces so
eventually like all the different
factions that you saw during daredevil
season to that the punisher was going
after they will be one faction united
under Wilson Fisk i'm only expecting to
see shades of that as we move into the
big defenders team up even if he's not
the big bad of the first season of The
Punisher I feel like it'll probably a
classic punisher villain like they'll go
for the easy slam dunk it will be jigsaw
someone who your kind of familiar with
but also flows from a lot of the stuff
they've done so far
if you didn't know the showrunner has
already been hired he's coming from
Hannibal I just love the idea that the
person who was responsible for Hannibal
Lecter is going to be authoring punisher
season one and there's rumors that
microchip is going to be part of the
series he's kind of like a Melvin Potter
gladiator type character someone who
helps the punisher with weapons gear
missions but then later like in later
series he becomes a villain so they go
up against each other so there's a
number of different ways that the series
could use them but so far he's the only
officially confirmed character that
they're looking at right now but they'll
be plenty more as they start working on
the series so while defenders is
the culmination of all the different
netflix series so far just expect all
the series going forward to weave in
aspects of that select jessica jones
season 2 which is going to be happening
after defenders will acknowledge
everything that happened so far but it's
not going to be tied to what's going on
on Luke Cage season 2 or daredevil
season 34 punisher season one it'll just
like loosely weave in bigger plot
elements Wilson Fisk in the hand or just
the best examples of that and for those
that are asking we haven't talked about
it recently but there is a jessica jones
season 2 that's been greenlit it's going
to have multiple villains and it's going
to double down on the Hellcat jessica
jones friendship so for all of you that
have been holding your breath like
really hoping for Patsy Walker hell cat
stuff will probably see more of that in
season two as we get on and seasons
expect more characters to crossover
Heroes for Hire style like once we get
Luke Cage and Iron Fist obviously in the
next season of one of those shows will
probably see a whole bunch more iron
fist
during the next season of luke cage so
let me know in the comments
who do you want the big bad of punisher
season one to be remember that they will
follow up on some of the consequences of
what punisher did like Wilson Fisk is
definitely coming after him
family members of the Irish gang members
that punisher killed might be coming for
him
there will be repercussions so it's
going to be really fun to see how they
dance around all those things during
punisher season 1 but he of all the
characters he will be the most
under-the-radar just because he doesn't
hesitate to kill people in related news
my next video is either going to be the
Flash movie because they just announced
that cyborg is going to be a big part of
that
oral-b flash season 3 so be sure to
subscribe to get that i'll be doing both
videos i just haven't decided which one
is going to post first so you guys can
let me know which one you want first in
the comments where you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for the luke cage trailer and you can
click here for my infinity war teaser
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight